my name is jane dybal i've worked for
37 years in the music industry
and i've worked at
small companies like virgin and huge
companies like warner's
and i've run companies uh as well myself
so
um i've
met lots of
people i've worked with lots of um
really brilliant artists
um and as i say it's been a huge amount
of fun
um
i'm also the chair of prima donna
festival uh prima donna festival comes
to stone market
uh every year um and we put on bands uh
we do lots of uh writing workshops and
poetry and we have lots of activities
for people of all ages
um
what we're trying to do is to
create a a place where
we can um
platform people or give them the
opportunity to appear at a festival if
they wouldn't otherwise have done
and
you might if you live in how many of you
live actually in stone market
a couple
you might have heard self-esteem on the
sunday afternoon i don't have any of you
heard of self-esteem the artist
she's really worth checking out she came
and played prima donna on the sunday
afternoon and she had it so loud i think
you could probably hear her in ipswich
but we really try and get interesting
new up-and-coming acts
to play
on the music stages i think the most
important thing to start off with about
an event in careers and of careers in
music and events
is to know that there's quite a
different way of working if you're
in this industry
so
for me most of my career i've been
employed and that means that i've got a
boss
and i get a salary every week
and i get paid and i get holiday pay and
i get sick pay
and
i have to go to work every day
but the music and events industry is a
place where you will find all sorts of
different kinds of people working in
different kinds of ways
and i think for you guys that will be
um more important than ever to to be
aware that if you don't want to work for
somebody there are other options
so we will be
talking to people today who are
consultants
now i'm a consultant i consult
businesses in the music industry
about how to strategize around their
business
and i get paid for the hours that i work
for them
there are entrepreneurs people who've
set up their own companies
and that's maybe because they've seen a
gap in the market
um
andy uh over there and phil who we're
going to talk to in a minute are both
examples of music business entrepreneurs
um and this is a place where if you have
an idea it can turn into your career
um anything is possible
and that's something that i really um
would emphasize you know is it's
it's not the case that you've got to fit
into boxes you can make your own box you
can decide the kind of career that you
want and
you don't have to necessarily go down a
road where you need to find somebody
who's going to employ you on a full-time
job
and some of the entrepreneurs that we
know
uh most successful in the industry are
people like ed sheeran um
local local hero ed sheeran
who has his own business and his
business has been built around his
talent so we'll talk a bit more about
that
later
but for the first
part of the
session today we're going to talk about
events
um and
how many different
roles there are in events and what we
would like you to do
um i'm going to get andy to come up on
stage
and his trusty assistant cat
are you in for this one um
and um
what
we would like you guys to do is think of
any job that you might think
exists
in events management and what we'll do
is we'll make a big list of them up on
the board and explain what's involved in
some of them
you